sara is with us in Las Vegas Nevada hi
Sarah how are you hi I'm doing well
good what's up well I have always been
someone to pay my credit cards and if
not be paying them off be paying the
minimums and now I'm at a point where I
need to decide how to approach the fact
that I can't pay them do I just let them
sit do I call my creditors do i what do
I do
what can't you pay them I am recently
separated and buncher the credit card
that we had to pay old unquote cash to a
rehab center for my husband and then he
came back and things were not better and
so now I'm paying rent for a house for
my kiddos well my name is still on a
mortgage and I was back to work and my
take home is 550 twice a month I'm sorry
so what's he addicted to a little bit of
everything he was the one that got me
started on the debt free thing but he
went to rehab when I found him sneaking
out in the middle of a tactical gambling
[Music]
mm-hmm and this is going on quite a
while obviously yeah I didn't know about
it for a little while he kind of muddied
up our finances to know I mean his his
addictive behaviors have gone on yeah in
the last couple of years yeah how old
are your kids ten six five four okay and
the vote the vast majority of addicts
are broke or on their way to broke so
I'm assuming you all have no money yeah
his job a week after he said I was
moving out and I'm he's making seventy
two hundred
there went my health insurance so by the
grace of God I got a job I have health
insurance but it's costing me 963 every
weeks which is why my take-home is 550
we get a I get a little bit of
supplemental income because they adopted
the little one we adopted other ones
they were substance exposed so I get
1700 a month to assist in caring for
them because they have special needs but
my rent is a thousand and our mortgage
is a thousand so kicked around the ideas
at home on the market you know it is not
weird that it will not be sold I just
checked the mortgage and he swears a lot
of the things it needs to be sold yeah
well so far he stayed up to date on it
until he doesn't have a job no I know
okay we're not gonna be in denial
anymore okay this guy is not reliable
he's not got a bad heart but he's an
addict you know hundred percent the time
they don't pay their bills eventually
eventually that's why you left yeah you
can't make a life with him until he
until he gets cleaned up and gets healed
and so it's why you made this hard harsh
economic decision for you and these
kiddos I'm sorry you guys need to you
need to be very forceful and get this
mess cleaned up because it's gonna come
down on your head you've got the your
name on that mortgage is there any
equity in the house I talk to the banker
a few weeks ago and she said she thinks
there's about thirty thousand equity in
it bankers don't know anything okay
their bankers you need to talk to a real
estate agent and get this thing on the
market jump online at Dave Ramsey comm
and get an ELP real estate agent let's
get this house on the market and call
him and tell him he's getting ready to
sign a listing agreement and cleaned
that house up and get it ready to show
because your kids need $30,000 you're
barely making it here how much credit
card debt is there
my guess is between 60 and 70 thousand
your guess so you've not added back
because I know that we paid fifty seven
thousand just for the rehab and then I
know that since I moved out he's been
living on his credit cards and I you
have my name on all of these cards what
that is your name on all these cards no
my name is only on two of them which is
about forty thousand okay that's all
that's your problem okay and call those
people right now and close those
accounts to further charges okay does
he's got his name on there too he can
use them right
no I they're gone he has no access to
them okay good that's what I want all
right and so we're limiting the amount
of damage if he runs up a bunch of cards
in his name that's his problem
right okay I'm not happy for him I wish
good things for him but I'm trying to
protect you in these kids right now
right that's why I got the legal
separation paperwork so 40,000 bucks is
going to come down on your head and you
can't pay it today Oh No
okay so there's not anything you can do
about that today you're doing all you
can do you've got your plate full with
the numbers you gave me you feed those
kids you keep the lights on you keep the
wolf away from the door and that's
that's a full-time job for you right now
you're barely making that yeah you know
there's no chance you pay these guys
right now so here's what's gonna happen
it's gonna mess up your credit oh well
least of your problems
right right so you just call them up and
tell them if you want to but it doesn't
matter whether you tell them or not they
don't care they're turkeys and they're
gonna be butts to deal with get ready
for them to go crazy get ready to hang
up on them a whole bunch but it doesn't
matter your job is to protect these kids
and you first we'll get to the credit
card debt later I'm gonna help you we're
gonna put you through Financial Peace
University so you're in a community
where we can help you this hold on
Gabi's gonna pick up this is the Dave
Ramsey show